we're told in this question that on a
string instrument the length of a string
so let's call that L the length of a
string L varies inversely as the
frequency so varies inversely as the
frequency so L is going to be equal to
some constant times the inverse of the
frequency times the inverse of the
frequency and I'll use F for frequency
the frequency of its vibrations and then
they tell us the vibrations are what
give the string instruments their sound
that's nice and 11-inch and it's
actually the vibe it's the vibrations of
the string affecting the the air and
then the air compressions eventually get
to our eardrum and that's actually what
gives us the the perception of the sound
but we don't want to delve too much into
the physics of it an 11-inch string has
a frequency so 11-inch so this is its
length so the 11 is string has a
frequency of 400 cycles per second so
this right here is the frequency a cycle
per second is also called a Hertz find
the constant of proportionality and then
find the frequency of a 10-inch string
so they say an 11-inch string so 11 so
11 inch string is equal to some constant
of proportionality times 1 over 400
cycles per second so 1 over 400 cycles
cycles per per second all right second
is sec so to solve for the constant of
proportionality we need to multiply both
sides by 400 cycles per second 400
cycles per second multiply the left-hand
side by 400 cycles cycles per second and
the left-hand side becomes 400 times 11
well 4 times 11 is 44 so 400 times 11 is
4,400 and then we have in our units just
for out of interest our units are cycles
times inches per second so it's cycles
cycles times inches in the
later of our units divided by seconds
and that is equal to our constant of
proportionality so we can say we can say
that the length the length is equal to
forty four hundred forty four hundred
times and or forty four hundred cycles
cycles times inches per seconds I want
to get the unit's right per second times
one over the frequency times one over
the frequency so we solved for a
constant of proportionality and then we
can use this to find the frequency of a
10-inch string so now we're talking
about a situation where our length is 10
inches so 10 inches 10 inches so we get
10 inches 10 inches they are equal to
4400 as you can imagine these units are
that a little cumbersome but 4,400
cycles
times inches times inches per second
times 1 over the frequency times 1 over
the frequency and so we can do a couple
of things we could just multiply both
sides of this equation by the frequency
so that it gets out of the denominator
so let's do that let's multiply both
sides by the frequency by the frequency
and then we could also divide both sides
by 10 inches to get rid of this and then
we'll just have frequency on the left
hand side so we divide both sides by 10
inches and then we divide it by 10
inches 10 inches the left hand side
we're just left with the frequency we're
just left with the frequency on the
right hand side we have 40 400 divided
by 10 4,400 divided by 10 is 4 440 and
then you have in cycles inches over
second divided by inches well the inches
cancel out with inches and you are just
left with cycles cycles per second and
then obviously 1 over F times F cancels
out to just being 1 so we get our
frequency when our when our string is 11
inches long or when our string is 10
inches long our frequency has increased
to 400
recycles per second from when it was 11
inches when was slightly longer our
frequency is 400 cycles per second when
our string got a little bit shorter one
its shorter now it our frequency
increased by 40 cycles per second